Modelos de programação são especificações fundamentais que definem
como o software é estruturado
e executado — eles fornecem um framework
para que desenvolvedores expressem algoritmos
e organizem o código, muitas vezes abstraindo detalhes de baixo nível
do hardware subjacente ou do ambiente de execução
diferentes modelos são adequados a diferentes tipos de problemas
e arquiteturas de hardware, oferecendo
diferentes níveis de abstração
e controle. Neste capítulo,
vamos revisar modelos de programação quântica e clássica
e ver como podemos combiná-los para operar algoritmos
em hi
vamos começar com o modelo de programação
para um computador quântico. Um modelo de programação fundamental
que é familiar a quase todos os desenvolvedores quânticos
é o quantum circuit. Não vamos entrar
nos detalhes dos quantum circuits
aqui, pois já temos muitos recursos excelentes,
incluindo uma aula de Joan Waters.
Vamos apenas mencionar que o circuit é construído a partir de
um conjunto de linhas chamadas fios, que representam qubits,
bem como gates, que representam operações sobre estados quânticos,
e um conjunto de medições.
Outro conceito importante de modelo de programação
para
essas primitivas representam as tarefas mais populares
que os usuários buscam realizar com o computador quântico.
Existem duas primitivas disponíveis neste momento:
Sampler e Estimator. O Sampler oferece a capacidade
de amostrar um estado preparado por um quantum circuit,
e o Estimator permite estimar o valor esperado de
um observável para um sistema no estado preparado pelo seu quantum
circuit. O conceito final
que vamos discutir nesta seção
é a transpilação. A transpilação
é o processo de reescrever um dado circuit de entrada
para corresponder à topologia de um dispositivo quântico
específico
para execução em computadores quânticos ruidosos.
Semelhante a compiladores clássicos,
uma rotina de transpilação altera gradualmente
a estrutura do circuit aplicando um conjunto de passes.
Agora vamos falar sobre modelos de programação clássica.
Existem muitos modelos de programação
para computadores clássicos,
mas neste capítulo vamos focar em dois:
os mais populares — programação paralela
e fluxo de trabalho por tarefas. Usando esses dois modelos
em combinação com modelos de programação quântica,
é possível expressar praticamente qualquer fluxo híbrido
quântico-clássico de qualquer complexidade.
O modelo de programação paralela
divide um programa em subproblemas que podem ser executados
ao mesmo tempo. Existem dois paradigmas principais de programação paralela:
paralelismo de memória compartilhada e paralelismo de memória distribuída.
Para nossos propósitos aqui, vamos focar no modelo de memória distribuída.
Um modelo de memória distribuída
usa processos independentes em núcleos separados
ou nós, onde cada processo tem sua própria memória
e a comunicação acontece via troca de mensagens. Há
alguns conceitos que serão úteis conhecer.
O primeiro é o processo,
que é uma instância independente do programa
sendo executada em um núcleo separado.
Também o rank, que é um identificador único do processo,
e depois há o modelo de abstração de programa único
com múltiplos dados (SPMD),
que é um modelo de abstração
para computação onde uma única instância do programa
é distribuída para múltiplos nós.
Assim, o código-fonte é o mesmo,
mas os dados nesses nós são diferentes.
A execução no modelo de programação paralela
acontece da seguinte forma:
um único programa é distribuído para múltiplos nós
e inicia múltiplos processos paralelos.
O fluxo de controle do programa é ditado pelo rank,
ou pelo identificador do processo,
e a comunicação acontece
via troca de mensagens.
Um modelo de programação de fluxo de trabalho por tarefas
abstrai a computação em um grafo ou DAG (grafo acíclico dirigido),
onde cada nó do grafo é uma tarefa específica
ou job, e as arestas são dependências de dados
e ordenação. Exemplos podem ser encontrados na nossa documentação.
Afinal, a sequência sobre a qual sempre falamos em computação quântica —
mapeamento, otimização,
execução e pós-processamento —
é um modelo de programação de fluxo de trabalho por tarefas,
onde todas as tarefas são executadas uma após
a outra no pipeline.
Mas com fluxos de trabalho por tarefas,
não estamos limitados a uma ordem de execução sequencial
e podemos executar tarefas em paralelo.
Cada tarefa ou fluxo de trabalho pode ser um job paralelo completo
por si só, então você pode combinar
esses modelos para descrever algoritmos
de qualquer complexidade.
Vamos tentar aplicar alguns dos conceitos que aprendemos
ao código. Primeiro, vamos tentar rodar um simples hello world
usando o paradigma de programação paralela.
Vamos usar o Open MPI,
que é a implementação do protocolo MPI,
que é o padrão para troca de mensagens
em programação paralela.
Primeiro, precisamos ter nosso programa pronto.
Aqui estamos usando mpi4py,
que é o binding Python
para MPI, e como você pode ver, estamos usando o rank aqui para decidir
o fluxo de controle do programa.
Então vamos verificar nosso script de submissão.
Como você pode ver, vamos usar dois nós,
uma tarefa por nó na partição normal,
e vamos rodar nosso programa. Vamos esperar um pouco
e podemos verificar os resultados do nosso job.
Como você pode ver, temos as saídas de log do nosso programa.
Aqui usamos dois nós e dois processos,
que são identificados por um rank.
Como você pode ver aqui na saída,
rank zero e rank um, que foram usados para decidir
o fluxo de controle do nosso programa.
Como você pode ver, o processo rank zero enviou
uma carga útil para o processo rank um,
e o processo rank um a recebeu.
Vamos também falar sobre fluxos de trabalho por tarefas.
Existem ferramentas chamadas sistemas
de gerenciamento de fluxo de trabalho, especificamente projetados
para executar fluxos de trabalho complexos,
mas para não sobrecarregá-lo, vamos usar o recurso integrado de
dependência no Slurm
para construir esses grupos computacionais.
Primeiro, precisamos ter as tarefas do fluxo de trabalho
prontas. Este é o mesmo código.
O benefício de ter cada uma dessas tarefas —
mapeamento, otimização, execução
e pós-processamento — como etapas separadas
é que podemos especificar requisitos de recursos únicos
para cada uma das tarefas. Por exemplo, mapeamento, otimização e
pós-processamento não precisam
de acesso a recursos quânticos,
portanto podemos executá-los na partição clássica.
Mas a tarefa de execução vai precisar
de recursos quânticos, portanto vamos executá-la na partição quântica.
Agora vamos usar o recurso de dependência para encadear tarefas
em um fluxo de trabalho.
Como você pode ver, ainda está rodando
nosso sbatch com a flag --parsable,
que vai retornar o job ID,
e então podemos passar esse job ID
como dependência para outras tarefas
ou jobs. Como você pode ver, estamos rodando
jobs no fluxo de trabalho com a dependência.
Assim que todo o fluxo de trabalho estiver concluído, podemos verificar os resultados.
E como você pode ver, temos nosso valor de expectativa de volta.
E também podemos verificar todos os
resultados de cada uma das etapas.
Que também estão aqui.
E é isso para a seção de modelos de programação.
No próximo capítulo, vamos falar sobre algoritmos avançados.